[Music]
in mayor Ford a news submitted by asked
the meals a youtuber became mayor of a
US town band straight people and got
immediately impeached oh my god I sound
like my story
I mean if Trump can be President
anything can happen should I go should I
should I aim higher and go for like
governor or senator or clearly he was
doing that as a joke or a political
statement the rock said that he would
run for president and it's so funny
because some people are like the Trump
people are like I would never vote for a
celebrity and like you know what's crazy
my favorite politician what I have a
couple but one of my favorite is Jesse
Ventura I mean he was the governor of
Minnesota Jesse the body was a wrestler
he's a wrestler and he was a Navy SEAL
well he was there's not one beautiful
one in Canada Justin Trudeau or the
president or prime minister
yeah he's oh he's beautiful I didn't
know if he I looked at him and I
realized because he's so charismatic and
so handsome he would make the perfect
serial killers Oh cuz nobody will
suspect him whatever happened to Kim
Kardashian want to be mayor of Glendale
really you never heard about that
because she's Armenian oh I think uh I
think Glendale ian's wanted her to be
the mayor
I thought she announced it's Oh from now
on everybody wears ed hardy no no when
you play basketball you must call
everybody bro bro bro bro less baseball
bro come here bro you must drive
expensive BMW but live in one apartment
with 17 other people you can only share
with : yeah this bro wear tracksuit
[Laughter]
you know you've got a [ __ ] uncle like
that Park in Glendale for a year and
that's all I [ __ ] soul tracksuits are
comfortable though even in the hundred
and ten degree weather must wait next
the Russians no tracks means man are you
just track suits no borderline Russian
right now close to each other all right
so this youtubers name is Elijah Daniel
and first names god I just realized that
I really do not know any other youtubers
like their cool I mean yeah outside of
the circle do man that you two world men
they know everybody everybody like hey I
know you from Bella I don't know the
[ __ ] you are do you think they watch us
or know who we are they well the way
they watch YouTube they they develop
their YouTube by looking at everybody
else's YouTube we did when we did you -
we just did whatever the [ __ ] we wanted
so we didn't have to look at other
people's content to see what they were
doing
yeah and then you see like our views
drop were like well we gotta see what
other people are doing we still don't
really watch any of you to anyone else
is there like a database you know I
think there's IMDB for like movies you
know is there YouTube it's like a top
100 youtubers and [ __ ] like that there's
a yes it isn't a social blade or some
[ __ ] like that yeah social blade isn't a
social blade I might check it out or bid
stats
oh yeah bits death does anyone yeah it's
like the the multi million subscriber
like white youtubers I don't know
anything about them like I recently met
Aaron and Alex was sloppy I was like who
who are you people I don't know anyone
outside the circle
it's weird I don't made the new would
not don't we know Alex yeah yeah like I
only met him once to be filmed at his
house and he's they told me you two I'm
like cool no he was pretty big but it
was it was cuz his content was for kids
in the very beginning so it was him in
um Alex Alex and uh guava guava Roy
guava juice yeah I mean they they made
my kid contacts yeah yeah that's why you
would have bad
so they're like hey everybody like just
happy - oh I got ya like that's like oh
we're a little bit in now
now they do challenges and stuff I knew
him back then
I forgot how we met but I knew him back
then yeah they just had a different car
you wouldn't watch it cuz you know
you're older but we were already oh yeah
way older at that time oh yeah so back
to this youtuber that we don't know his
name is Elijah Daniel and this is
Christine and they both share two
YouTube channels together and apparently
they're vloggers don't mess with taxes
they share YouTube channel together yeah
to their halala to do vlogs apparently
they do look that's a great combo like
because they don't look like anything
alike in terms of how they can conduct
themselves and how they dad they don't
look like homie
oh yeah yeah it's like super opposite
like I want that jacket
they look pretty interesting yeah so
Elijah he ended up tweeting that he
spent two days calling towns asking them
if he could be their mayor and so
finally he found out Cole that you can
be a legal mayor of Hell Michigan cool
does this town he called hell where do
you live I live in hell no one wanted to
be the mayor of hell oh my god I'm so
cool I'm the mayor of hell yeah must be
really hot there
he ended up treating this quote as of
today August 30th 2017 I'm the legal
mayor of help Michigan this is real I am
the mayor of health you tweeted that
along with this photo gates of hell
that's awesome
and then this certificate would you like
to read it do you see where as the town
of hell Michigan needs a mayor and
whereas no one else wants a job and
whereas being the mayor of Hell can be a
devil of a responsibility and we're in
divisions are the word we're us in for
shits and giggles that doesn't run with
me maybe it's old English and whereas we
have finally found a sucker who actually
wants the job now therefore we the
citizens of Hell Michigan do hereby
proclaim it Elijah Daniels to be mayor
of Hell Michigan on this thirtieth day
of August 2017 or until someone better
comes along
signed by
deep cleansing Odom Odom plenty former
mayor of held Michigan signed sealed and
singed inhale hey that's cool they
didn't have a mayor before this a little
burn white singed yeah like a theme park
I really embrace the whole city is being
play into it like a theme park he
tweeted this out it went viral and a lot
of media outlets are picking it up too
like what does youtuber because the
juicier part of this whole story is the
fact that immediately he tweeted out as
acting mayor of Hell Michigan I hereby
ban all heterosexuals from entering our
town and so he and just tweeting this
wasn't that long thing is that a joke
ask me
well here's legally the mayor of hell
and he is a youtuber
he's gonna do stupid shock drama things
for fun so there so the reason why he
did this is because he was saying that
he was kind of doing something similar
as to the one that was issued by Donald
Trump with the whole band that the
travel ban that happened so he was just
kind of like I mean obviously this is a
joke yeah poking fun at it and so this
went viral and here ended up tweeting
these to tweet
what does it say it says although I
enjoyed my time as mayor I've been
informed that I've been impeached as
mayor of Hell this will not affect my
presidential run a impeach was fun at
Donald Trump you should try it this is
like when a bet kinetic 1980-something
or sell me something Playboy magazine
say back when they actually had like
good stories they published a segment
it's a story about a world where
straight people were treated differently
and pretty much beaten up for being
straight and gay people were the norm I
saw a video like that yeah and then he
got so much hate for it like what's his
name Hugh Hefner you got so much hate
for it he said well if you can do it one
way you should see what it's like on the
other way - yeah that's what he was
trying to accomplish it's just a joke
right how come he got impeached I think
it was all part of I think it was a
pre-planned he that you knew that he was
gonna be mayor they knew he was gonna do
this ruse they knew that he was gonna be
impeach and it was all for that one line
treat that last yeah Donald Trump you
should try see mine is each smaller than
we think
yeah we're just giving him too much
credit to so he'll they have this
package that if you pay $100 you can
become legally the mayor of hell for a
day cool and then every single mayor
that pays so I did like an amusement
park because then every single mayor
ends up getting impeached but then the
way the media was spinning it like
because he banned imagine being the
citizen to that town just so [ __ ] sick
and tired of everyone's [ __ ] like this
is one guy just wants to live his life
in peace and one days and I can't
scratch my ass today because it's
illegal next thing is I can't [ __ ] in
the toilet this guy's pretty cool yeah
what would you what would the one lobby
that you guys would make that will cause
chaos for one day chaos yeah hey don't
think about chaos dude I think about
order I want chaos I'm trying to fix
problem would be your lovin what do you
mean if you were in this guy's or let's
say we go to Michigan you become mayor
they tell you'd pass something where
would you pack got too many and all
Chinese mainlanders [ __ ] Japanese
game show the whole town you're not
allowed to laugh today
oh the guy comes out in space you in the
butt yeah we'll have like guards and
everyone with sticks walking around
everywhere and then we'll have jesters
running around - uh-huh
no so it's like a Halloween Haunt but
then with people doing funny [ __ ] all
over oh no I'm fine I would love that I
would love that I'm not that creative so
the only thing I can think of is I would
make it a rule that every single
restaurant along with salt and pepper
have to have I know you bought a [ __ ]
bottle do you know I've been eating so
much fruit sweet
oh it's so good oh my god what about you
David Chinese yeah good bad Chinese man
ladders for a day and I bet you then we
just want to come in more yeah it's like
what you think I can't come in I mean I
think you know with that I'm just
thinking of all pictures the purge in my
mind right now you and you I'm thinking
who someone in someone would probably do
the purge not me not us but someone
might do it did you see the thing that I
wrote on Facebook it's like a day it's
like the purge but instead of people
killing each other
customer service people who say whatever
the [ __ ] they're thinking oh that's
awesome
I would love that yeah you're my love
it's called freedom don't be a bit today
what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] links in the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then that
videos are up there
[Music]